yes I know there's a new Jason Bourne
movie coming out with Matt Damon I saw
the trailer for that and that's very
exciting but I just saw Krang in two
trailers I got to talk about Krang
but first of all this Ninja Turtles
movie coming out that I am literally
split there is a duality in my brain
about it because they still put Michael
Bay on the trailer which freaks me out
but there's a new director behind this
one then there was behind the first one
Michael Bay is not directing this movie
nor did he direct the first one well the
first one you see his fingerprints all
over that the thing about this new
Ninja Turtles movie that I've seen at
least for me in the trailers is that it
at least looks like there is an attempt
to make a ninja turtles movie bebop and
rocksteady shredders a human being and
then in the first trailer you saw those
things floating across the city and some
people I saw in the comments section of
my video were like whoa was that
Dimension X sure enough you see Krang in
this trailer it's not even like is that
Craig no that's Krang those are you not
no Krang is from Dimension actually the
brain then he had his brain is in the
stomach of this big robot yeah you look
at the CGI in this movies pretty
cartoony we're not it's not Planet of
the Apes and a part of me it's like
maybe they're keeping it cartoony so it
doesn't freak kids out can you imagine
that a big cyborg with a brain in his
body I mean kids would probably be like
mom mom yes Timmy and that will come
after you if you don't eat your green
vegetables so go ahead and do that it
has been making an excuse that's the
only reason I could see because as I
look at the CGI in this movie it looks
pretty cartoony but at the end of this
trailer something super cartoony happens
look not visually cartoony but just like
physically it's actually kind of dumb do
like where's Raph and Raphael splats on
the nose of an airliner that's in the
air let me rephrase Raphael splats on
the window something going a few hundred
miles an hour
yeah the turtles are tough they're not
that tough I know turtle power is a
thing that we all sing about males sing
about but turtle power does not negate
an airliner when it hits you so I'm
concerned about that kind of stuff I
feel like they're gonna go so far into
the slapstick realm the movies actually
gonna lose its relevance which is a
bummer because now you have everything
that you need to make a Ninja Turtles
movie that old-school fans wanted to see
a bebop Rocksteady shredders a human
being you have Krang now that I saw
Krang I'm more interested than ever I
mean it's not gonna have the heart in
the family feels of the very first Ninja
Turtles movie that came out in the 80s
what could it do the old cartoon justice
it's certainly good I could actually do
the IDW comic books justice - are you
guys still the new Ninja Turtles trailer
with Krang have you seen it what did you
think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more